This is a hub us.
So Darla,
y'all can't be seen in this.
Behind every memorable character is a
meticulously chosen wardrobe.
Whether the costume is extremely flashy
or completely blends in.
Costume design provides an amazing
opportunity to give us insight into a
character and the world around them
because just like in the real world,
what you wear says a lot about you.
I'm always said there's an awful lot you
can tell about it.
Posting by those shoes.
I want to take a look at costume design
as a tool for filmmakers to tell their
story.
In many of cinemas,
most important movies,
costume designers are the secret heroes,
the people who immerse us within a world
seamlessly and effectively without
getting nearly the same recognition as
actors or directors.
So let's get sketching the plus to hod
dialing.
The word costume invariably gets
associated with how the wean dress up
and pretending to be somebody else.
And sometimes that's the function of
clothing.
In a movie,
he was,
didn't pick a moon,
but the majority of costume design
operates on completely opposite
principles.
Their goal is to create authentic and
realistic people on the screen.
Not Actors playing dress up.
Oh,
it's not a costume.
Costume design is an added layer towards
the immersive magic of film period.
Clothing is meant to place you in the
time period of the movie.
Gone with the wind is famous for its
engaging costume design of while there
is some 1930s flare in the hairstyle,
the clothes still manage to immerse the
audience in the civil war era and
accurately reflect scarlet's fall from
grace.
The way she designs her own clothing
also serves as a nice metaphor for the
need to literally and figuratively
reconstruct herself after the war.
At its best.
Costume design is a vital layer of world
building and it works well in totally
foreign places.
When people talk about the original star
wars,
they usually praise the plot characters
or special effects with the costume
design was also fantastic.
It combines what we're used to seeing
with the completely alien princess
layers.
Costume design is right in the middle of
looking like she's from a foreign planet
and looking like royalty as we
understand it.
And all the designs,
the robots,
generals and soldiers,
their wardrobe is alien enough to
transport us to an exciting and
different worlds,
but familiar enough to keep us grounded.
And while we already understand our
immersive costuming is more difficult
than you may think edith had the winner
of eight Oscars for costume design and
the inspiration for edna mode designed
for many movies taking place in present
day.
So she just dressed her characters in
the style of her time.
Problem is by the time the movie was
shot,
edited and released,
the style would change and the dresses
became tacky.
So she had to anticipate the future and
make something look modern but not tied
down to a specific trend.
And she was one of the first to address
this issue.
That's still shows up today,
striking the balance between looking too
dated or too generic.
So a movie made in the 70s might have
generic costuming,
but a movie about the seventies embraces
the old school style to bring about the
nostalgia of a loss time.
It's why eight mile looks like you could
have taken place at any time,
but rappers look ridiculous in their
music videos that came out the same
year.
Fashion is not the primary.
The primary effort in motion pictures is
to tell a story.
The plane hoodie works as a blank slate,
emphasizing mnms quest to succeed purely
on talent and nothing flashy while also
attention on his face.
Either way,
costuming is supposed to compliment the
style of your film,
whether you're going for realism or
something more flashy.
Along with our immersion,
many costume choices are to make
characters stand out of their worlds.
Willy Wonka's introduction takes place
over 30 minutes into the movie and the
praise always goes to gene wilder is
amazing performance,
but it's also an example of great
costume design while all the other
characters dressing clothing stylized
from the late 18 hundreds or as cowboys
and other characatures won because
wardrobe is a hybrid of the Victorian
jacket tail.
And buttoning of the 19th century,
but the collar and color scheme all
embody the style of the 1970s so we get
a character who visually stands out as
both out of his world and ahead of his
time.
The costuming in the remake emphasizes
the out of this world part,
but it has no grip in reality,
so it makes him seem more like a cartoon
caricature than an out of touch
visionary Bonnie and Clyde takes place
in the 1930s but their style,
wardrobe and obsession with the media
put them right into the 1960s it helps
make them appear antiestablishment much
like the young people in the real worlds
during the making of this film in 1967
Michael Corleone,
where's his military uniform to stand
out amongst the classy gangster suits,
but as he gets sucked into the life,
his clothing makes the appropriate
transition for gangsters.
Wardrobe indicates a transition into the
Mafia.
This example of costume design actually
does play into the initial concept of
wearing a costume.
The gangster gets new attire to try to
fit into high society,
but no matter what they stand out as
gangsters.
In many movies you can tell they aren't
really high society.
They're just playing dress up
gangster
like other gangsters.
Walter White place dress up to help him
feel like a gangster,
but eventually he becomes the gangster.
He was only imitating before costumes.
Give us insight into the character
wearing it.
Luke skywalker's wardrobe has the visual
aesthetic of martial arts gear implying
he's undergoing training.
Obi wan Kenobi is dressed like a monk
because he's doing the teaching in the
force awakens the roles that have
reversed and so have the costume
choices,
new teacher,
new students,
the shoes and the opening of strangers
on a train tell us which character is
more well off and which character is
more of an every man.
It may just be me,
but the black and white shoes looked
somewhat menacing.
They really stand out in the frame by
being so bright and flashy.
Tyler durden is costume design in fight
club always contrast the color Palette
of the setting and other characters
almost like he isn't supposed to be
there in the first place.
Along with actor personality and
direction,
color scheme and costume design is an
impressive and effective way to make a
character stand out or blend in in 500
days of summer.
The opening title sequence establishes
the wardrobe color for the two
characters,
Brown for Tom and blue for summer.
Throughout the movie,
the coloring shifts around them.
When summer enters Tom's world,
the setting is colored Brown.
While summer's world is blue,
the dance sequence has all the actors
dressed in blue to represent Tom.
Thinking about summer costume coloring
gives us mental cues as to how the story
is progressing.
And by the end of the movie we realize
their colors don't mix and they part
ways.
Movies become classics when all of the
production elements come together to
make something great.
And that includes costuming.
So when you look back at your favorite
characters,
think about what they're wearing.
And of course remember the most
important rule of costume design,
not kicks.
Thanks for watching.
[inaudible]
slightly trends full,
just a bit of a break from the norm,
just a little slot in the break.
The monotony of all that.